perhaps the biggest crime of Atlantis
Milo's return is that despite a very
obviously cheap animation budget and oh
I don't know obvious identity as a chief
cash in which is trains me how the
person was not a huge box off his head
it's that at first it actually kind of
has an interesting story yeah at first I
was kind of sucked in by it despite all
the bad jokes and awkward drawn scenes
and narrate let's look at the story Milo
is still living with Keita in Atlantis
but all his friends return saying that
apparently some sort of a Atlantean
monster is attacking a bunch of ships
confused by this Keita journeys to the
surface world
bring a Milo along with her and they try
to figure out if this monster is an
actual monster or one of the Atlantean
machines or maybe something else or even
someone else they go on land come across
this creepy village talk to all these
semi creepy people and the more and more
they find out about this mystery the
more questions it seems to raise there's
actually a lot of talking and even kind
of ominous dread and I mean that in the
best way even though it wasn't animated
the best I was actually finding a kind
of interesting but here's the thing when
they do find out what's going on and
what's behind it it seems to raise even
more questions well that's fine but we
never get the answers there's questions
about where the person who's doing this
came from and how he's able to do what
he's doing is he even doing what he's
doing is he conjoined the monstrous the
monster controlling him how can he
possess other people is he possessing
other people it looks like he has to
look into their eyes wait now he doesn't
need to look in their eyes how does this
work and just as it's getting
interesting they completely drop the
story yes they defeat the bad guy and
then they go to a completely different
story now it takes place in the Wild
West and they're these wind coyotes and
I don't know some guys is stolen
and they have to get it back but there's
this Native American who can control the
winged coyotes and it somehow connects
to the Atlantean stuff but it doesn't
stop there it then goes to another story
where this crazy guy thinks he's Odin
and he steals the spear that has
Atlantean technology which actually kind
of makes him Odin now and he confuses
Keita for his daughter broom-hilda and
this is just another pilot for a TV
show isn't it
that explains why the animation was this
way and why all the stories don't really
connect that well damn it at least with
Harvin and Jane I knew it was going to
be a pilot to a TV show this tried
harder it fooled me into thinking it was
going to be something that tried hard
rock the whole thing I guess it does
technically have an ending and yeah the
endings not that bad it even kind of
reckons the ending of the first film but
it's weird when you see the choice she
makes you understand her reasoning but
there's also like a ton of dangers that
happen throughout this film to go
against her reasoning to nothing what
happens is the wrong choice I'm saying
they never explained the actual dangers
that could come along with it and that's
very important to address so yeah I
guess in terms of other technicals the
voice actors are all replacements and
they do a good job the animation like I
said is a huge budget cut but for kind
of TV animation I guess it's fine
sometimes there's a really inventive
idea like there's this annoying dog that
kind of sucks but he was born in molten
lava
so he'll Council II do things like just
sleep in a fireplace that's not creative
and again when they're actually kind of
talking about this ant lanty and stuff
it is kind of interesting kind of like
the first film in that respect but sadly
it just doesn't stay focused and I don't
even know if it was actually meant to
stay focused this was probably supposed
to be three episodes that were going to
be connected like I said as a pilot of a
TV show a TV show that never got off the
ground I mean okay I don't have
confirmation of this but if it wasn't
then this really is the most fragmented
direct-to-dvd sequel ever so I guess
it's not awful it's just not needed and
not that interesting through the
majority of like I said with the
exception of that first third but even
then that's not great it's just telling
an interesting story that never really
has any conclusion or answers I guess if
you really liked the first Atlantis
movie and you just want be a little bit
more the technology world and ideas
you'll get hints of in here so if you're
looking for something more this is
something that should definitely stay
sunk
[Music]
you
Oh
[Music]
you